[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're in the month of December
in the year 2022 so it's time to start
reflecting you know on our activities
and what's one of the most important
activities that we do buy stuff no this
has become a tradition it's just become
a tradition it's kind of fun it's a good
way to look back at our year to just to
look look at our Amazon purchase
histories I think this is at least 30 or
we've done it in a row who knows what
comes from it it's a good way to reflect
not to just brag on I mean you can see a
lot of you will see some of this some of
the stuff that I bought is not is not
braggy it's uh
it's uh
it just it kind of highlights a lot that
I've gone through this year
specifically like trying to get my dog
to not poop in the house oh oh like so
you know what that reminds me oh you
just you're adding something to your
list so we each have our own list we
haven't shared it with each other we're
going to share with you at the same time
because this is real these conversations
are real they're not rehearsed
it's the first time we've ever talked
about these things what does suck if for
every episode we had to like rehearse
the episode and then redo it it'll be so
weird especially if you found out that's
what we were doing
well yeah some people who just do a
podcast
you know
but but we we have found a way we we
have found a way to do the um
and I mean actually it ties in well with
the reason we're doing this episode
because when you do a podcast that's
basically every week of the year or the
maybe a couple breaks and you do other
things when you come up with something
that fills a spot in the schedule like
hey we talked about our Amazon purchases
last year that went well let's do that
again yeah you always go back to it
let me in one sense unless you don't
like convenience so you can hashtag your
biscuits and let us know if if this
should be the last year we talk about
our Amazon purchases but we would love a
suggestion for a replacement episode
188 earpod one if we want if you want to
like yell at us about why would you
replace it when we can start with
something very exciting right out of the
gate like my most recent recent purchase
yeah reaching
measuring spoons
oh look out watch it
you don't you you haven't had measuring
spoons
we did have a bunch of measuring spoons
but it suddenly got whittled down to
just one the tablespoon
and I find you want to measure like a
cup how many tablespoons do you need to
know it's not it's not the larger than
tablespoon measurements that are a
problem because I still have like a you
know like a Pyrex cup measuring kind of
thing it's the teaspoons
and the half tablespoons of course you
know I'd have zero need for these things
so like I'm just like uh well
interesting to have them but I don't use
them of course you don't bake but I mean
if we run out of spoons it's I might eat
with one but here's the thing it's not
for baking
because I don't really bake it's for
supplements and smoothie type things
right because okay I I've been doing a
number of things like
um I put hey this doesn't make it taste
good but I put olive oil straight olive
oil in my smoothie really long story
I'll probably talk about it at some
point but I did this like program where
they like test your blood and uh oh a
long story that ends in you just putting
an olive oil in your smoothie let's stop
everything I want to hear that right now
it essentially is and because you know I
think they should be a sponsor at some
point so I'm not going to say who it was
but basically they do a blood test and
then it gives you all these biomarkers
and then it gives you lifestyle changes
and nutritional changes in order to
address some of your deficiencies or
whatever and so I've got like high LDL
and so one of the ways to lower that and
maybe some other things that are wrong
with me would be is more Omega-3s you
can get that in olive oil so it was just
add two tablespoons of olive oil to your
to your diet every day you know hmm so
it's like okay I'll do that and they'll
and I cook with olive oil but I also
put it in my smoothie now because why
not right but you didn't have the right
spoon well but then I also uh I take
creatine every day and so that's
supposed to be like a 500 gram which is
approximately two teaspoons which is
approximately two-thirds of a tablespoon
you take you know I I do think we have
to
have an at least a part of an episode
where you go through all this stuff that
you're taking because
I don't I don't like to think about this
stuff and I think there's some of it
that I might need to be taking
and I'm just like you take so much I
would just like for you to step through
it and why but I don't want you to do it
right now because well you know I'm in
Holiday mode well let me just say also
that there are much better podcasts from
going through the supplements that you
should be taking but I can give you my
rationale at some point which is just
going to be a a more listening to watch
another podcast watered down rationale
of another podcast all right
um but so I've got this tablespoon has
become like me like eyeballing what a
third and what two-thirds of this is
just not it's not working for me and
also I'm like what happened to that
thing at one point we had like the whole
keychain of measuring spoons and then it
just we it once they separated it was
like they all went into different places
in the house and now all I got is a
tablespoon so
feel somewhat re-centered because that
has come and now I have the whole thing
let me make you feel better because I
know you like you you chalk this up to
like your your family's
Mo of like you guys lose things and your
drawers are chaos you know I you know
open any drawer in our house and it's
and it just is so perfect
I love I love it and I love that Christy
and I are the same but I'll make you
feel
um better or at least I don't know what
it will do but I will tell you I have
noticed that our main spoons
they've been disappearing
like I actually had a conversation with
Christy a couple weeks ago I was like
where are our spoons like the normal
Spoons the ones that I use for
everything
and she's like I don't know but I
haven't been noticing that they're
dwindling I was like I think we need to
buy more spoons and then it kind of kid
issue it kind of came down to Lincoln
It's gotta be I was gonna say it's like
I think he's he like
he's I think he's throwing away the
spoons because he takes he takes all
these dishes to his room and then I've
learned whenever I'm about to run the
dishwasher I I've I've developed this
habit right before I hit start on that
puppy I usually do it late at night like
right before I go to bed nothing makes
me happy and waking up to like clean
dishes in the dishwasher
well a lot of things make me happy
and a lot of things but nothing like
that nothing like that
so I've started going like making the
trip into his bedroom and just like
scouring the place for bowls and spoons
but apparently
like like a rat Nest there's going to be
like some Nest somewhere that's just
like made out of spoons in his room that
I haven't found yet oh that still think
what's happening is he like does he grab
a spoonful of peanut butter and like
walk to his room
he eats from what I can tell what's left
in the bowl it's Ramen
have you seen Ramen with a spoon I think
he has a fork and a spoon
okay well we need to talk to him about
that first of all
um since you're start you want me to
move on since you're starting with your
most like recent purchase I'll start
with hours
and pretty much all of these are mine
except this one is a collective one but
I I did approve it
because Christy knew that I think she
knew that like it could lead to some
sort of a conflict
vickerman seven and a half foot tall
silver
tinsel fur artificial Christmas tree
unlit faux silver
she was like
I'm gonna get another Christmas tree
um do you want a gold one a silver one
or
I think she was like it also comes in
Orange I'm like what the hell I don't
want a damn Orange Christmas tree she
was like well I'm just throwing it out
there your mom's coming in for Christmas
this year maybe bronze and uh
we get I want I want some I want it to
be as festive as possible I'm like you
know what that's a good idea and I don't
have an opinion on this if you want to
go where's the Apparently is there right
now absolutely well it's in the garage
at the creative house because no no I'm
saying when you this is a box you're
gonna have one in the living room and
one in the like family area is that the
plan yeah I think there's like maybe
maybe it'll be in like the foyer the
entrance you know
and then just we have one across from
the piano and like the main room when
you first walk in the house that's where
we put it
and we have to like shimmy a bunch of
trees around you know Christy and her
like plants and trees
all that has to there's like a whole
musical chairs of like we gotta move
this tree in order to put the Christmas
tree here and then we gotta move what in
so then the tree goes where the big plan
is and then the big plant goes where the
smaller plant is I'll I have to move
eight different things and it's in a
strategic
round robin in order to make room for
the Christmas tree and now I think we're
putting another one in the back you've
opened just so you understand you have
opened the door to a place that I would
never want to go yeah my wife tries to
get me to go there all the time multiple
trees I don't understand why and I don't
want to sound like a you know like a guy
from like 1986 comedian complaining
about his wife
so just take this with a grain of salt
but
I just feel like my wife
say Jesse let's start doing that first
of all why because
the my wife thing in 2023 no but I got
to stop but I'm playing the guy from
1986 right now okay
my wife Jesse is that a good compromise
for this year yeah I'm also doing it so
that when you actually export Clips you
know that I'm talking about my wife and
not and who's Jesse I could be talking
about Jesse Helms remember him
oh God
not real yes
um so North Carolina senator
um let's leave it at that I appreciate
first of all I mean she is so in both of
our lives so very much skilled at making
a space so welcoming
if it's supposed to be festive it's
going to be festive and a tasteful and
compelling way that makes everyone who
comes over to your house feel great
makes you feel great when you're in the
space
but for some reason I can't accept the
extra effort and inconvenience that
comes from the decorative process so
when you because you know it's going to
be on you and a second tree I know dude
that's why she asked twice Christy was
asking me what color it should be but I
think she was really just giving fair
warning there's a whole other tree we
are one we are she manipulated we are
what I'm asking you the wrong question
yeah and and she threw the mom card your
mom's coming in this year and Mom loves
trees
yeah we need to do it up for my mom but
yeah this is going to be honestly you
fell for it immediately I mean I'm not
saying I would I would have gone along
with it I fell for it but I would have
not acknowledged that I was being
manipulated and you know the thing I
didn't do and I didn't realize it until
I freaking read it out loud
what which of these words is the trigger
word seven feet
actually no unlit I'm freaking lit what
the hell Christy my wife
what are you doing buying the unlit tree
I think I have to go I have to click
right now cancel this order and then
reorder a lit freaking Silver Tree did
you not discuss that part I totally
forgot because that was the big
breakthrough was like we bought the lit
tree and now because man I bought a
literary one time and we still had to
put more lights on it because part of it
didn't work
so I mean that's a and we can't even
store it at my house like I got to go
over to the creative house garage get
the tree that we bought a couple of
years ago because it won't fit in my
garage without being seen and I refuse
to have things stored that are seen
yep don't even get into it that are seen
I like things but I have freaking
cabinets and everything's behind a
freaking cabinet okay I gotta freaking
light this tree all right well
I feel for you
we do have four trees in our house I
will say that already but we're only one
that's like normal sized I think I you
know what now they're three or small I
was getting excited I almost said so I
have fallen victim and we're gonna get a
live tree again this year yeah and we
get a lot my mom's coming yeah
one live tree and then three small fake
trees yeah I mean it's it's it's it's
just a run around
how about this one try this on for size
uh coarse sea salt
coarse sea salt now is this for bathing
no but some of these purchases this is
like a scrub I actually noticed in
looking at my list of purchases this
year which were uh
I mean most of them are not I have a
couple of Big Ticket items okay but the
most of them most of them are like core
sea salt which probably costs 10 bucks a
big thing of it is based on something
that I learned a lesson that I learned
that now I am applying in life but like
can I guess so you said it wasn't a
scrub
does it go in your mouth still you're
not gonna guess it of course I could
give you an hour and you wouldn't get to
it is it for cleaning because that's
that's what I would use it for okay yes
but do you know what it's for cleaning
what is for clean what it's cleaning
what it cleans that's what I use it for
uh
uh cement
stains no in your driveway no
um I'm not sure how entertaining this
guessing game is going to be okay what
cast iron pans okay yeah so
a big Revelation this year for me was
the embracing of cooking on cast iron
you know you hear people talk about it
all the time and then I we had one
because you've always everybody's got
one and then you start cooking with it
and you're like I don't like you what
you can't clean it what you can't you
soap but what what like it just seems
like an inconvenience right yeah and
everybody says that they're like
non-stick but actually they're not
everything sticks to them
so this year I don't know what it was
but I just you know what it was it was
freaking Tick Tock that's what it was it
was being unable to avoid people giving
you tips on how to do things correctly
and so yeah somebody like talking about
a cast iron pan in a tick tock and being
like if you just do it like this it will
become the best pan that you've ever
owned and so I was like okay screw it
I'll do it and I did it and it is the
best pan and now I have a bigger one
and then one of the things that I
figured out
um through another tick tock not the
same Tick Tock is that a great way when
you're done cooking with it to clean it
is you kind of you know you kind of get
everything you can out of there and then
you just put a bunch of coarse sea salt
in there heat it up really hot and just
take a paper towel and just sort of like
move it all around in there and it gets
everything and then you just take that
under the sink with some water and you
just boom boom boom and then you put
more oil on it heat it up and then leave
it there and it becomes super seasoned
and it's just been revolutionary for me
it the interesting thing about this
is that I not only know all of this but
I have personally experienced it this
we're experiencing a strange
intersection between the two of us yeah
because I
I you know I don't cook
I've already established that with the
spoons and everything else I've talked
about ever about cooking
but
and I'm it could have been on Tick Tock
for me as well I'm a cleaner and I saw a
tick tock where somebody got bought a
um
like a worn down skillet
that was like rusted
and then it resurrected they resurrected
it
using those techniques there's a good
stuff's under there it doesn't go away
it just gets because I I watched I just
watch cleaning stuff
you know on Tick Tock and on Instagram
so that came up for me and then I don't
know how it happened but we had a a cast
iron skillet that I think I used
on the grill yeah
to like saute onions to go with like
Smash Burgers
and then I left it out there and it it
it got rust I've done this and um I was
really dejected
and so
I
I don't know which happened first but
yeah I uh I used this the sea salt and
you can and you also use you put oil on
it you have to oil the
when you're done you oil it and you heat
it up again and then wipe that down so
you want it to be really oiled and you
can kind of store it with some oil so
that it like uh yeah you know so like
coated in oil so it like stays I just I
honestly I just leave we leave both the
big one and the small one on the stove
at all times I don't we don't even we
don't really have a place to put it up
so it's just like that's what we cook in
and it's there all the time
um let's let's promote something okay
what are we promoting we're still good
we're still good uh you know the game
that we created along with uh Spin
Master that
um many of you have already played and
many of you have been talking about the
good times you've been having with
family and friends playing party games
party games it's a nice little box that
you can take in your luggage to wherever
you're going like for the holidays is a
great gift it's also a great thing to
play
with your family because it it takes
like hilariously ridiculous disasters
that everyone helps create and then
everyone helps pitch the the best
positive spin on that to say we're still
good so it kind of it it it's um it's
just an injection of positivity into uh
your family or friend gatherings I think
I'm gonna play it with my my my extended
family over the holidays you should is
it weird to play a game that has a
picture of you on it well it's a cartoon
picture of you and you can maybe they
won't notice okay
uh but the here's the big update it's
now available at mythical.com yeah it's
been at Walmart it's been on Amazon
and you can still get it in those places
but now you can also get it at
mythical.com if you're already filling
your holiday cart over there and you
definitely should and you can get like
points and stuff we're doing like you
know you can get like oh really points I
think over at mythical.com now so maybe
I don't know either are or are we going
we're going to
all right my next thing
uh recent purchase Behringer Zenex 302
USB Premier 5 input mixer with xenex mic
preamp and USB audio interface two other
things to go with this so you can try to
guess what I'm doing
day better 50 50 RGB LED light strips
kit work
with Alexa and Google Assistant
Smart Wi-Fi LED strip lights 100 foot
two rolls of 50 foot LED lights for
bedroom decoration
and finally
standard XLR mailed a female
I like the sound of that
balanced microphone cable durable and
flexible noise canceling six feet black
I mean this is clearly ehsb stuff
I've never said ehsb yeah that was kind
of snuggle baby that's right
um
foreign
are you going to try to are you doing
something in your bedroom though because
there was a bedroom light thing bedroom
light was one of the descriptors
bedroom decoration so you're going to be
DJing for your wife are you trying to
incorporate the Elkhound into
I love making I'm setting up you know
how our our bedroom is is Big it like
has a whole seating area like at the
foot of the bed yeah I would say
unnecessarily large I know but it's just
it's a function of the space underneath
it
that then created a bedroom above it
that was like just so big
we could have a party up there
party for two
so
okay
party you know your table's ready party
of two
I'm setting up a DJ
um practice area a DJ
console set right there facing the bed
so like and it's gonna have lights
it's gonna be it's gonna have visuals
they are potentially going to time out
with the music that I'm playing so
yeah I'm gonna be doing DJ sets I'm
gonna be going snuggle baby mode
right there now and I'm lying about part
of this
so that can't be the case no your wife
wouldn't let you do that in the bedroom
she wouldn't let you put your practice
facility in the bedroom I'm setting I'm
I'm gonna set it up at the creative
house and the thing that I've
ah I I I don't want to commit to this
but like I bought this stuff which is
like trying to get me to commit to it
um I was listening to
John for Shante guitars for the Red Hot
Chili Peppers talking to Rick Rubin you
know I got a thing for Rick Rubin and
anything he does in podcast world
you're talking about
um
great series of interviews where they
talk about the production of their their
last two albums and for Shantae if
you're really into guitar stuff you
probably already like John Frusciante
but
um he talks about his practice method
and then he gets his guitar down uh and
he and he demonstrates how he warms up
and he talked about his philosophy of
practice as its own art form like he
doesn't practice
um
he he doesn't practice what he's gonna
play on stage when he tours he doesn't
get really good at that because he's
improvisational all of his guitar solos
are like
just off off the top of the Dome so it's
it's very much about him just like
developing his skills for like
hours before every show and he's amazing
you know it seems cool like someone
who's as amazing to see is that puts
that much work into it but it really
stuck with me when he talked about
um he saw practice at his own art form
he invented ways to engage in a totally
different
mode
um than how he performs and then he it
subconsciously bleeds in and makes him a
better performer
and I was like you know what I bet you
there's something to that
uh for me you know because I I need to
practice my DJing more
and but I love an audience
when when the Sunbeam furniture place
opened you know that Jesse decorated and
and Christy helped her and did like the
the plant stuff uh for that event they
had a DJ which was not me but I talked
to that DJ she was super nice and she
talked about how over the course of the
pandemic along with a lot of DJs she
started Twitch streaming
and um so I I'm putting those two things
together and I'm my idea is to
not just practice but to stream it like
so I'm not you know just to create uh
yeah because if I'm gonna if I'm gonna
practice I might I might as well have an
audience you know I think that would
motivate me and you can stream uh any
other songs it doesn't like that's my
understanding yeah
um they don't employ the technology that
like Instagram employees that like well
they'll take down your stream so it's
it's a it's a squirrely area but um
yeah that's where DJ's stream unless
something's changed in the last month or
so
uh and then my hopes will be dashed and
then I could just do a muted stream
where you can watch me but not hear me
DJing but I'm just trying to develop it
as like
not a performance but a practice as an
art form that if anybody cares to be a
part of it they
uh it'll be streamed you know so it's
it's I'm it's gonna be very low-key I'm
excited about that but I want to set it
up at the creative house because that
that way I can just kind of step step
into it and do it and it and But
ultimately just so I can practice more
so I had to I I just went on one blog
and like they said this is all the stuff
I needed to buy and I was like I'm not
going to overthink this I'm just going
to buy this crap and I'm going to set it
up
so that's my intention I'm putting it
out there
um
somebody on YouTube somebody parked your
Elk Town snuggle baby already but I have
to believe it was a fan so reach out to
me if you're the one who parked Elkhound
snuggle baby on Twitch
reach out to me
um well you can reach out to them too
uh I I couldn't see how to do that on
Twitch
so right now it's link underscore
Elkhound snuggle baby
but well so it's gonna be one of those
it's gonna be one of those
um I don't know when I'll do it but I
will where are you setting it up at
tweet it out
I thought I would set it up where um
I guess I need to get your
your approval of this since we're we're
equal on this this not in my office so I
was thinking like you know where the
records are and the record player is
like
where that couch is
if I could just rotate that couch out
and then like the backdrop could be the
those records
and apparently some LED lighting
so you have to change you have to set it
up every time you do it
I don't know that that's kind of what I
was thinking that then like I would just
move the
maybe the table can live right behind it
I don't know
I don't know there's probably room by
there
um okay uh mine's mine's a little
simpler if not I could do it in my
office my next one's a little simpler
the Red Devil uh
Venom mouth guard
why would you need a mouth guard
again another
revelatory thing that I learned that I
figured out all on my own okay
okay so me you didn't listen to a
podcast no it's just this is just a
observation about myself based on things
that people have been telling me so
I've been going to
you know like since the pandemic
we started winding down and we started
going back to the dentist one of my most
recent trips to the dentist uh was
actually after
um
we
we had eaten that crazy sour thing on
the Vanity Fair or whatever that was
that thing we shot where we eat that
sour candy that was straight malic acid
and they were like no one has ever kept
the candy in their mouths nearly as long
as you guys did we didn't expect you to
keep going and going and going but you
know who we that's what we're going to
do we're up the same place we're
freaking us and I actually think I did
permanent damage to my enamel on my
teeth I know we were both scared uh and
they noticed that and when I'm scared
I don't think about it like something's
wrong with my teeth I'm not going to
think about this anymore and and when
and when and it happened to you too and
you did the exact opposite I took action
you took action so I ended up getting
like some like enamel repair toothpaste
or whatever but one of the things that
the dentist pointed out was she was like
with the hygienist was like she she
legitimately asked me
did you get your teeth
shaved down what like like for some sort
of like I was like like you mean for
like a religious ritual or something
she was like
your incisors look like they're they're
not they're flat they're not pointed do
you see that
they're not yeah like your dog teeth
right like your eye teeth they call them
yeah yours are pointed and mine used to
be pointed mine are very pointed and so
they were like well you're obviously
grinding your teeth at night so I went
to the whole thing of getting the mouth
guard for at night which I now have and
which I do wear
but I was like I don't think I grind my
teeth at night but you don't really know
because you're asleep
and then I started realizing that every
time in my life for the past 45 years in
which I have been doing something
intensely
I grip my teeth like this I put my lower
teeth over my upper teeth my bottom
teeth come out my dad does the same
thing it's just like this so like if any
sports moment in my life you'll see it
even when I like throw a dart on Good
Mythical Morning like
I do oh wow I I and I just been like
I've been doing this all my life
and I do it when I lift weights
and I've been doing it when I lift
weights forever and I started reading
about people who do weird things with
their teeth and they lift weights and
they're I've been damaging my teeth for
years and in fact last time I went to
the dentist she was like
she was pointing at those teeth and
she's like you're basically down to the
pulp on those teeth like you don't have
anything else left protecting those
teeth so I'm probably gonna have to get
like crowns or something at some like
fake teeth at some point in my life I
know a guy but
uh in the meantime of course like anyone
who like seriously and I don't like
seriously lift weights I just like lift
weights for ongoing Health you know
but so oh my God so I thought you would
say You're Gonna sleep with it
I have a sleeping mouth guard which is a
completely different thing this is like
an athletic mouth guard that like Steph
Curry wears when he plays basketball
and so because biting down when you're
lifting weights is actually like
scientifically proven to give you a
certain percentage increase in strength
just because of something about like you
know
it and which totally makes sense because
that's why when you're really trying to
do something you bite down and I would
bite down like and it's just yeah I've
been just like ripping these teeth apart
for years
so anyway I've stopped the damage now
and I work out with a mouth guard
and I encourage you if you lift weights
on a regular basis or do anything
Physically Active that's interesting get
a mouth guard you might as well
Cherry Pig solar mole repellent
ultrasonic mole repellent solar powered
outdoor waterproof ultrasonic snake
repellent for get rid of mold gopher
snakes vole and other underground pests
four pack
pretty obvious right I'm actually
surprised that it says snake repellent I
love that so I got four of these I had
some of these
and I got rid of my moles
uh in my yard
and some people have bought mole
repellent thinking thinking that they
can rub it on themselves yeah this is
like it's like a steak that you put in
the ground it's got a little solar panel
thing on top I bought them the moles
went away uh my yard got even again
and then somehow
they disappeared they might be under
Lincoln's bed with a nest full of spoons
I don't know but I had to buy four more
they don't that it's not poison it's you
know it's just a sound
um so I put I staked it out and uh yeah
it works like a charm it forces them
into my neighbor's yard
um Underground
but yeah that's that's their problem has
that do you know that for a fact
um based on the reviews
yeah there was people describe how if
you do it in one area then they'll just
move to another area and so the only
area for them to move in here is my
neighbor's yard I mean maybe they went
all the way into the woods I don't know
I don't care but I mean I think that my
neighbors would probably send them into
my yard so like everybody's got to work
together everybody's got to work
together
um
the only thing I don't like is that it's
like a it's not a constant so it's like
silenced and it's like
um
so every time I would go outside it was
kind of unsettling
you can hear it yeah
yeah
it's got to be like that ultrasonic well
it says ultrasonic it's not freaking
ultrasonic I would just call it Sonic
because I can hear it
it has to be uh it has a cut on and off
because otherwise you would they adjust
to it
potentially I I don't know that's a good
theory
that's what I bought it does work but
then after a while I get annoyed with it
and I take them up and then eventually
like it took about nine months for him
to come back and maybe it was seasonal
but uh the moles voles or whatever they
are came back
so
I recommend that you're not killing them
you're just shoeing them makes you feel
a little better about it or you could
find a way to catch them and eat them
I'm not that hungry
I could probably find some recipes on
Tick Tock for like mole stew stew or
something put them in that nicely oiled
skillet
um
this purchase comes with a story I
bought four items uh two
Carolina Panthers hats and two Carolina
Panthers shirts
I remember I remember seeing you wearing
this once and it was just one of those
things where it's like you didn't ask
any questions I thought I told you this
I
so this was some is this a James in the
shame yes so something so I had a PR
person working on like right around the
launch of the album with me on some like
press opportunities
and
one of them was I guess it was Spin
Magazine has has this thing where they
do like
musicians give predictions for their
favorite teams in FL season and she was
like would you be in do you watch NFL
do you have a favorite team and would
you be willing to do this and I was like
yes a little bit and then to the second
question
I mean I am I'm an NC State football fan
I like college football and that's what
I watch but I consider myself a Rams fan
being in Los Angeles but I have a you
know an affinity for the Carolina
Panthers only because they're in North
Carolina but like I don't really keep up
with it and I don't own any Fan Gear so
what I said is
yes I'm willing to do that yes I'm
willing to do this and I'm I can do
either the Rams or the Panthers I feel
it just there's probably somebody else
already representing the ram so yes and
I'm like the reason I'm doing this is
because of the press opportunity so I
did so it's all an illusion so the first
thing I needed to do was
uh fine you know get close
I don't I mean I don't even I don't know
because they were putting a picture of
you yeah they wanted a picture of of me
in Ram's gear I mean in uh Carolina
Panthers gear so I had to find some
and based on what I saw
of you wearing that stuff
I don't know if it's a great PR
opportunity well I'm just telling you I
mean looks like a dork dude well
can I just say and I hate to say this
but like
it's very difficult to dress up
in support of your team and not look
like a dork I know and I got it it's
like you're cosplaying as like it's what
everyone thinks a fan is it's like well
are there people who are fans of sports
that also like to look cool you can for
some reason this is this is I I have a
theory this is it
they make the stuff out of the same
material that they make athletic
clothing out of a lot of times it's like
these t-shirts had this like moisture
wicking dry fit like so much of this
stuff has this in case in case you need
to go out there well these people are
just watching on the feet guys like when
you go watch a concert it does yeah you
can get a cool t-shirt that is like a
cotton t-shirt or like a 50 50 t-shirt
you can get a cool hat that looks like
someone who is ready to watch something
fans of athletic performances should be
able to wear the same things that fans
of musical performances wear you're not
playing hey you need to shut up this is
a business opportunity
we need we need to keep this to ourself
till we're ready to launch they just
don't make any cool they don't make
enough cool stuff even like I would wear
more NC State stuff I would but like you
it is just like a needle and a haystack
because there's like a shirt that's cool
like like like the Retro Retro logoing
is is one particular Avenue to coolness
well even like and it's Wednesday it
hasn't brought back they brought that
back yeah they brought back the wolf but
then the stuff that they put it on it's
like they're they're still in this
athletic mode like I was like what do
you guys think I'm doing I'm sitting on
a couch and then standing up at moments
and then sitting back down on the couch
and now I don't know posing moisture
material here for Spin Magazine so what
did you I never saw this photo did it
happen oh yeah it was just a selfie I
took it in there
um you were wearing what a Jersey no I
wore a T-shirt and a hat but even that
still felt like hey this doesn't feel
like me but like I'm I mean that's what
they wanted
the other piece of this puzzle is I had
to come up with my prediction for the
Carolina Panthers season
so at that point I just texted my dad
and said Dad uh a research project for
you newly retired man who also doesn't
care that much about NFL football but
likes college football in Georgia
like he quickly like just came back with
like he's your ghost writer here's what
I think
and now I will say that if you read the
article any funny parts of it
your dad wrote I wrote because my dad
didn't make it funny it was very much
just like here's bullet points
including my obsession with the Long
Snapper for that I added that okay it's
the Long Snapper snuff stuff because I
am genuinely interested in Long Snappers
and the Johansen I think his name is is
like played like 16 Seasons without
missing a game or something anyway so
yeah I had to get I so I if you're if
you ever need any Carolina Panthers
stuff I got two hats and two shirts we
could go out together that you will
never wear again
uh yeah I also I just didn't come from
it did you did you get any lessons from
the from Carolina Panthers fans that
you're now completely undermined I think
the name of the story I think the name
of the article was 56 musicians predict
their take on their NFL NFL season like
yeah who else
some people that you would recognize and
a lot of people that you wouldn't
so I'm maybe I got one lesson from that
it was worth it
that that's the world of PR man oh yeah
oh my gosh
um oh here here's a here's a there's a
sweet one
um
Where the Sidewalk Ends
the book
I'm familiar with Michelle Silverstein
and um you know uh the the I didn't
write it down but also we just got a
bunch of like our favorite you know kids
kids books a couple of Shell service
things like The Light in the Attic uh
Where the Wild Things Are
and this was did you get the issue of
Playboy with his famous interview did
you also get that
yeah nice touch yeah he's a you know he
wrote A Boy Named Sue for uh Johnny Cash
he's like he was he was in that World
The Outlaw country World anyway but but
cool thing
um this was in honor uh do you maybe
you've seen these
um there's like if you take a walk with
your dog in a neighborhood or if you go
to certain parts of town you can see
there's like these little libraries they
look like a bird box yeah but it's a
it's a library where you can exchange
books you can put a book in take a book
out and
um Christy did this with well her sister
Brittany and JB they ordered and then
her dad Bobby my father-in-law built one
of these boxes and then they painted it
custom color and they put the plaque on
it and they put it up in honor of the
you know their first daughter passed
away like hours after being born and she
would she would have been 10 years old
sayla would have been 10 years old this
year so every year they they celebrate
her life and then you know they're
they're they're
other kids they they now have two more
kids I got a niece and a nephew
they um you know they learn about Salah
and and the story of even even through
all of that pain that like
um it's it's become something that's
they've
it's been very beautiful you know in
honoring her memory so like for her her
um
her 10th birthday they created one of
these boxes so we were able to buy uh
books for it in the neighborhood or they
put it up in front of their house they
put it up in Lillington at the at the
Ballpark you know where you and I did
the Fourth of July where they do the
fireworks every year played baseball yep
hundreds of times and where we where we
did our fourth of July wax paper dolls
concert
um yeah they actually put it up there
and we were because we went in we went
back for Lance's wedding
we were there for like the like the
ribbon cutting
so we were able to put the books in
there and you know honor sayla's life
and memory and just you know it was a it
was a great family moment
to be a part of that and um yeah I wrote
down the name of the
littlefreelibrary.org oh so you can just
make one there's a number of places to
register it that will do it but if you
go to
littlefreelibrary.org you can order the
pieces and they'll send it to you and
you can build it and paint it yourself
and then you can like
they'll send you like the plaque to put
on it so that in in their case it can
say and and loving in honor of Salah
um and then you know it's in it's part
of the community and and it looks really
cool and
nice and of course I got permission from
the ballpark to put it there
that's awesome so yeah um
littlefreelibrary.org it's like a and
you know you can do it for whatever
reason you want to just do it to
contribute to your community but like
you know there's lots of kids who are
like taking walks and or like hey let's
go to that Library let's see what books
are in there now let's put some of my
favorite books in there it's like you
think kids are doing that yeah
definitely kids still got books yeah
that's the thing it's kind of this retro
thing that like gives you a sense of
connection and being a part of something
and until you unless you in real life
analyze it yeah I mean this isn't a good
place where it only takes one
yeah
sadly that's true but um when you talk
about that place uh the the Lillington
uh ball fields there yeah
they're so nostalgic to me because of
the smell which I it was a it was a mix
of dirt grass popcorn and cigarette
smoke that I felt like I smelled
repeatedly as a child playing outdoor
sports that was so pronounced at that
particular location that I'm sure it
doesn't smell as much like cigarette
smoke anymore because it's just so much
less time for people to smoke well we
went it it the other cool part of it was
that morning
our nephew Nehemiah he had a he had a
soccer game there on the field so like
we watched him play and then we that we
dedicated the library took some pictures
um but I was like yeah it's wild to come
back here I was telling
you know telling Lincoln Orlando it's
like I played t-ball on these fields but
you know because I hated t-ball it makes
you feel anxious when you see that yeah
I was like my butthole was getting real
tight
um so yeah I choose to think more about
like all of the the the the fireworks
that's what I associated with the food
fireworks here fireworks every year
um
okay here's the next one from me five
pack USB wall charger and five pack
charger cables oh yeah this has to be
like an annual like re-up right I just
feel like again I I don't wanna I'm
gonna go into the dad dad mode
so the thing I have asked for
is so I have a charger next to my bed
right
for my phone it is a wireless charger
that I can set my phone on and I can
also put my airpods on and they can both
charge you
yeah and then Jesse uses a traditional
just USB cable that goes into that plugs
directly into her phone that's a shame
which makes her a prime target for
Shepard when he needs a phone charger
and because he is a 14 year old yep
apparently they eat these things what is
it I I believe I think that Shepard is
eating the cables
thinking that their pasta may be getting
into it's like a late night kind of
thing this is such a pattern
they're gonna like yeah they're go if we
like took him to get his stomach x-rayed
there would be like 17 USB cables in
there that's the only explanation for
how many of these we go through
and so instead I might as well just put
it on a monthly reorder well here's what
I did instead I I spent months
admonishing him
and then Jesse would get mad because he
would take her charger and then she
would need to use my charger and it's
the domino effect and so I just said
instead of having this repeated argument
which we have about USB cables and socks
we have the sock argument because I have
two boys who wear the same socks as me
and we share
yes I'm just giving so I I regularly buy
socks and I again I know I may be eating
socks as well
but I just said I'm gonna have every
room you go in there's going to be a
place to charge your phone
oh
cables yeah it's like everywhere there's
somewhere there's a charger
let me just say that I did this this I
actually did this purchase twice this
year
so there's there's 10
cables and 10 usb chargers
and we still do not have yeah yeah no
it's not going to work it's not going to
work it has to be hardwired you have to
screw them in it has to become a fixture
yeah you've got to like you got to sit
there and you got to like screw it
against the wall
he'll find a way you'll find a way he'll
not loose
um
Lube life
water-based personal lubricant for men
and women mm-hmm flavorless 12 ounce
uh
yep
I purchased that now I will say
Lube life is a weird brand it was very
highly rated and I was just you know I
didn't want I just it was like the top
of the list
needed to re-up on you know
my lube and uh
I didn't realize how big 12 ounces is
when it comes to lube like this is a big
I mean it's like a can of Coke well it
but but but then it's thinner it's
probably this tall yeah it's like it's
it's it's a little less and half the
diameter of of a of a can of Coke so
it's like twice as tall as it can you
get it in your ass
foreign
I can't get it in the bedside drawer
okay so yeah first is the problem that's
then you start working on your ass you
gotta get I mean just so now
just a word of advice it's like you like
when it comes to lube smaller is better
you know ironically yeah because also
you went in the moment of passion and
you want to pull it out you want to be I
don't I'm a little bit Coy about it yeah
here I am getting up and running to the
bathroom because we have one drawer that
it can sit straight up because you don't
want to store it sideways and you've
already got a Hydro Flask in one hand
when you're making right so you can't
have another giant container right right
no hands with it
yeah exactly and and plus they're
they're marketing is strange like the
the bottle it it doesn't just say Lube
life it says hashtag Lube life like like
like they expect people to be sharing
this stuff publicly well you are now and
I guess I am
so it worked like that's my that's my
that's my resolution every tweet I make
in in 2023
is gonna have that hashtag yeah I I go I
don't go pay attention to the houses
y'all I don't go to I don't get it from
Amazon
and there's some other website that I
got my loop from this year I can't
remember what it was there's a um you
know when
sex with Emily podcast sent us the gifts
there was there was like a an
appropriately sized
Lube there that uh was more drawer sized
I've been using that
you what you can refill and I can refill
it from the from the big one just don't
let anybody see you do it I gotta I
gotta
yeah I got to get a Lube funnel now
um okay I'm gonna skip over a few here
since we're I wanted this to take
forever
um
60 pieces painted figures
60 people okay
um
what is this
I think this is an interesting way to
talk a little bit about our approach to
things maybe even 2023
oh so
you talking about Tick Tock well I
bought
60 little figurines that you would use
if you were like making if you were like
a train set train person you know you
did like toy train models and stuff and
you created a little town or like a
Christmas Village or something like that
and my idea at the time
was to buy some of these figurines and
then
write sketches
that just fig that uh you know featured
these figurines very very small I mean
very like close up you know kind of like
robot chicken-ish sort of thing but
ridiculous situations where you would
take
the specific figurines that you had in
this set
and make us to make a story based on
kind of what was suggested to you by
this set
so kind of an old school idea very much
an idea that I've had for even like 20
years ago back in the very early days of
of us you know the Fine Brothers used to
do some stuff with like figurines way
way back in the day that and it ended up
getting in trouble because it actually
figured they were doing like actual yeah
you know recognizable IP but this is
different
and that was when we were in our what
are we doing on Tick Tock and like are
we doing an original strategy are we
doing original sketches and you know if
you've watched our Tick Tock in our
short formal Instagram stuff like you
know we've done a bunch of different
things trying to land on a strategy
incidentally the strategy that we have
landed on at least right now is that we
do so much other stuff that generates
Great Moments and funny things that we
say and do that we should just use those
to fuel our Tick Tock so that's why if
you go on The Tick Tock right now you
see it's just all GMM Clips right yeah
now
but one of the things that I like before
that I like it and we'll talk about how
we're using that
the freed up mindspace time and energy
that we have by not putting making
trying to make like original sketches on
Tick Tock and what that means for what
we're trying to do because we are going
to put that energy to something that you
will be seeing so but we did make a
sketch
that I still think it we should put it
out I still think we should put it
outside of this conversation yeah we we
gave notes on it twice we we need to and
we re-recorded the video because we
didn't really like the vo that we did
the first time and it's ridiculous it's
a ridiculous thing that we still should
just put on Tick Tock because you and
you have those figurines on your desk at
the creative house so now at least you
have some Decor too and I like to play
with I like to like just like hold them
in my hands I feel like a giant playing
with little people
when I'm on a phone call
but yeah so just so you know
we are we're gonna release that we're
releasing we'll release we'll release
that but
a lot of the energy that we've been
putting into other things like that
stuff and stuff that you may not have
seen we are finding ways in 2023 to
funnel that energy into things that you
will see we'll talk more about that in
2023 in another podcast but just so you
know what you're what you're not seeing
in original content on Tick Tock you
will be seeing in other places soon
um I'll I will quickly mention Nature's
Miracle advanced stain and odor
eliminator 32 ounce oh I got one of
those now when it comes to the red
bottle
mine was different different brand but I
it was on my list I took it off what
because this thing I said at the top
about like
like trying to not get my dogs to sneak
and poop in the house is very difficult
it's really just a Jasper issue and it's
well yes definitely a lot more Jade will
not pee in the house but Jasper we had a
lot of problem with him peeing in the
house and that's why a contrary to lube
32 ounce is like the the minimum you
want
for something like this right I mean we
had to take the rug out from under our
dining room table completely when we
were like trying to train him and really
getting serious about it because once
they start peeing in a spot they go back
they go back to that spot
um
so we're not 100 out of the woods but
he's made tremendous progress
um a lot of progress this year with
Jasper like going on walks like I've
done a lot of training with him like he
doesn't he doesn't bark at other people
on walks anymore
um my treat game is on lock like I'm and
he's very motivated so I'm really proud
of him and then at home he's just he's
gotten he's just gotten a lot better you
know he's he's over two years old now
and I think he's finally getting there
and it took Jade that long too I've
heard that like it's a
it's a a Datsun thing house house
breaking
uh um but I just wanted to give an
honorable mention to that
I'll also give an honorable mention to
broom and dustpan set with long handle
kitchen brooms and stand-up dustpan
magic combo set Magic
combo set for home Lobby broom with
rotation head and standing dustpan for
floor cleaning
red
very excited about this I replaced my
broom why you you don't look as riveted
as you should be well I was I had a I
made a purchase about dog piss too and
so I was going to try to slip that in
there but then you moved on to a broom
yeah it's too late well no mine's way
better than yours so I'm gonna go back
to it okay cool
the broom
well first let's talk about a broom yeah
right
well it's not the broom it's the dustpan
the dustpan has its own handle and so
it's not like I the the previous dustpan
I had it would stick to the handle of
the broom and it became a unit so they
could stay together but now I've
upgraded to a dustpan with its own
handle tall handle and the broom and so
like there's no bending over and it's
just beautiful I feel I feel like one of
those people at Disneyland who just
walks around cleaning up like the moment
you drop some at Disneyland there's
somebody there sweeping it up you know I
do that in my house now somebody dropped
some I sweep it up and then here just
stream that on Twitch here's the yes
here's the Revolutionary part
there is teeth there are teeths coming
off of the dust pan
so that when I sweep it then I can put
the broom bristles into the teeth and
then come like move in a vertical motion
so it's an L motion and it cleans the
brooms and this is something that should
it's just rev a freaking illusionary
if you have a if you have a dustpan that
doesn't have his own handle
and if you and it doesn't have a bristle
cleaner on the dustpan
you must upgrade immediately you're
welcome
okay uh it's first thing I'm going to do
after this is I'm going to make that
purchase
don't you know what that's what I'm
gonna give you and everybody else I love
for Christmas okay spoiler alert
okay the only time I sweep is when
somebody makes it like there's an
accident
I feel like the rest is handled via
vacuum or dog
yeah back to dogs though because as you
know
similar struggles with Sean
Sean has been Sean is a problem dude
Sean it was you know Sean his fault's
advertising I talked to you about this
before when they said he was a little
anxious and he was house trained he's
very anxious and he was not house
trained at all well I freaking came into
the like two weeks ago I come into the
freaking office
and Sean's there and he's just barking
at me and I was like you know the best
thing I'm gonna do is I'm just I'm not
going to ignore him
I'm not gonna give him the time of day
I'm gonna walk on my desk so I take a
step by him and the dude freaking bites
me on the calf twice yeah I was wearing
sweatpants yeah well that's the one
aspect of his training that is going
well the training to hate you is the
only thing that he's responding to right
now no the interesting thing was like I
had on a hat and you said I think he has
an issue with got people with Hats well
our friend Jaden who's been uh when he's
in town has been staying at my place and
he's a great dog trainer uh one night he
said I think Sean has a thing with Hats
because and because if somebody that you
he actually knows comes in with a hat on
so maybe in his former life when we
don't know what happened to him in his
former life but things happen to Sean
yeah poor boy
um but he is getting better I took the
hat off and he did seem to chill out so
we've got to figure that out like that
whole thing of biting people is
obviously a big No-No
essentially like if somebody's entering
a room he has to either being he has to
be held or he has to be on a leash and
then you have to and then he calms down
but the thing that he's doing that is a
constant struggle is
uh pissing and [ __ ] in the house
and we talked to our trainer about that
now he will find a spot like and he'll
have like a [ __ ] spot for two weeks
and then it'll shift it's a [ __ ] spot
shifts yeah to somewhere else
uh
and he is better about not pissing
inside
but what we were doing you know we have
we don't have any real grass outside we
have like a teen inside is is much worse
it wasn't much worse so he has curved
that a little bit but we were talking to
the training where like
you know I just don't know if we have
the discipline and the amount of
commitment and time that it takes to
really do this in the right way like
give us give us some help so will you
live with us and the trainer said
because he had become scared of the fake
grass outside which is our only grass
uh I don't know I just I would love to
get inside Sean said
but I know one thing I would find there
is like nightmarish
uh fake grass so apparently somebody
with a hat took him out onto some fake
grass and did some ungodly things to him
in his past life
because he doesn't like either one of
those things oh poor guy and so but he's
a just he's adjusting very very well
like for somebody who of his of his uh
past but
she said there's definitely the same way
Jasper yeah he's totally a different dog
there's like there's some stuff called
uh fresh patch
which is just a patch of fresh grass
most often used for people who live in
apartments and they want their dog to
you know use the bathroom on grass and
you don't want to always have to take
them outside or whatever or it's like
so essentially it's just a piece of sod
that comes in a cardboard box
shipped to your door every two weeks you
get it right uh this is hot you know
first of all I think it's like 60 bucks
a month so I know that it's
significantly more expensive than if I
was just
going because I told Stevie about this
and she was like you could just go to
the hardware store and get a patch of
grass for a lot cheaper than that
and I was like yeah
but I have to go get it yeah yeah so
you're not proud of it but I'm not proud
of it yeah you're doing it so let me
tell you it works oh and now you're
excited about it it works and he like
immediately I don't know it's not in the
house it's outside on top of the
artificial grass no it's outside on top
of the concrete area because it's like
it's closer to the door okay and he like
immediately went out there and got on it
and started using it like something
clicked he was like this is what's
supposed to happen on this
um and then if it's raining I take it
and I move it to the other side of the
house that has like a covering like over
there on poolside yeah and it goes out
there and he uses it on that the problem
is is that unlike Barbara who would
never pee or crap in the house ever like
she is Barbara is
oh I tell her that all the time I love
her so much more
um because I'm my love is conditional
for dogs
and until sean gets his [ __ ] together
I'm not gonna love him as much
so
um
but he is getting he doesn't let you
know like Barbara goes to the door rings
the bell and then looks at you like come
on
yeah I did this I'm ready Sean a little
stupid so he's rung the Bell a couple of
times
yeah but anyway this fresh patch thing
it's really been the answer to to us
because that's because he's got all
these freaking rugs I mean Chrissy's the
same way like yeah they get these rugs
that are nice rugs a dog pissing them
and you can't you can't spray that
typical cleaner on those rugs
Like Jesse will not let me put any sort
of
pet spray she's like soda water only
oh I mean she'll break up a Lacroix and
pour it right on one of those things but
only soda water
you can't put cleaner on it look at the
life you're leading yeah I'm cleaning up
things with Lacroix and paying sixty
dollars
for a patch of freaking grass I I I've
already done my honorable mentions so
I'm I'm done oh really anything that you
want to
um yeah I mean probably I guess two
really quickly
including the most significant one
so one of the things I did this year of
course as it relates to James and the
shame is I had to look the part in terms
of like my photo shoot and album and
promo stuff and like hipster California
that kind of thing
and and in an effort to continue to
separate James and the shame from
whatever the Rhett McLaughlin brand is
um I was like I I gotta adopt some kind
of look here I'm not a cowboy hat guy I
don't want to do that you know yeah
um I'm glad but the uh
it's funny because the guys that I think
have like the best style in country
music right now is Midland right oh yeah
and
every picture you see of those guys it's
like Ah that's cool they're cool they're
cool but it's country but it's cool it's
a little fun that's why I like it and I
was talking with uh Brian
our CEO here business Brian he knows
everybody man that dude knows everybody
and
uh he ends up like yeah my friend is
their manager or something I can't
remember the exact connection but he
immediately like comes back with
uh the brands that they that they wear
oh uh you know we're looking you know if
you're looking for cool stuff so
they wear a lot of stuff and they I'm
sure they've got stylists for days but H
Bar C is like they're it's like cool
Western Wear western shirts and stuff
like that so a lot of the stuff I got
this year was from them and then because
I needed some boots because I just
didn't have any boots but I didn't want
to like if you go to like a western
store
and you get a pair of boots there's like
six or seven hundred dollars for a good
pair of boots I'm like I it's an art
form I'm not doing anything in these
things again I'm not this is like
unnecessary unnecessary moisture wicking
in a Carolina Panthers t-shirt yeah so
I found the brand takovas
Austin based
you know this is happening these people
are coming in and sort of
revolutionizing an industry and and
usually it's two guys who have an idea
who come together and they're like like
Thursday boots is like we're gonna make
boots but we're gonna make them more
affordable and our advertising is going
to be great and you're going to get this
on Instagram all the time and eventually
you're gonna break down and buy them I
think it's two guys because you're a guy
but I think there's plenty of two women
too yeah well I'm saying because yeah
I'm just saying I'm talking about for
the the for the products that are like
right for you for me and the uh and
takova's is an example of this they're
making like good boots that look just
like the really expensive boots that are
like 250 300 bucks for a pair which is a
much more reasonable okay anyway so I
got like a few pairs of those that has
kind of completed the James and the
shame look in the times when I've needed
to do that so we're doing okay we're
doing apparel shout outs I'll get yeah
I'll give an apparel shout out to
imperfix okay uh Cadillac Spanx
California based uh it's um
it's a it's a surf aesthetic company but
it's all a lot of canvas wear this
jacket and all of the other ones like
this year for me has been the like the
two-piece jumpsuit oh yes Revolution
right yeah I'm I'm obsessed with that
brand so uh very cool
uh aesthetic and like their story and
like their approach and there's a few
guys craftsmanship as far as I can tell
it's just one dude okay who uh I think
he's a surfboard shaper
hmm at least a lot of the images are of
a guy wearing these outfits shaping
surfboards well maybe you get into that
too nope
um and finally
my biggest ticket item my birthday
present to myself
something that I've wanted for a long
time and I tried to find ways to get at
it in a cheaper fashion and finally just
bit the bullet literally took the plunge
oh
and bought one of those cold plunge ice
baths
that were like featured on Shark Tank
but that was a birthday present right to
myself yeah but that was your birthday
present like my big ticket item last
year was my mountain bike I believe and
that was and I it was my birthday
present to myself yeah but I mean it was
the
it was the biggest purchase of the year
for me
and
you know you've used it because I mean
it's basically a bathtub with a box
beside it that then circulates and and
refrigerates the water so that but you
need has a top on it like a hot tub
would have on it yeah but it's shaped
like a bathtub yeah and it's pretty you
know he has an outdoor refrigerated
bathroom it's pretty aesthetic you know
for how these things could go because
what I was gonna do is I was going to do
aesthetic the the cheaper version which
is to take a
again there's a bunch of YouTube videos
Barrel well people do barrels with ice
in them but then you have to get ice and
put it in every single day you don't
know what the temperature is other
people will take an old oak freezer with
you know open top freezer and seal it
and then do this thing where it's like
on a timer so it's not on when you're in
in it and stuff but it's like a DIY
thing and it's got a freezer outside
and then I was like why not man just get
the one that looks the part and it's got
all the technology built into it and you
can dial in the temperature it's got the
ozone like filtering of the water in
there so it like keeps the water great
for like six months
and I've always wanted this because you
know I you know I mean I'm that's I we
know you know I I I'm I'm that guy that
is gonna
take the supplements and get real hot
and get real cold and do all that stuff
you need the things and uh I absolutely
love it
do you get in this morning I did I sure
did I'll get into it every day so now
you don't hate it
uh no no no no that's the point the
point is you hate it every time
you know what I'm saying yeah you hate
them when you got me to do it I did hate
it you especially the moment right
before you do it every single day yeah
you're like that decision am I gonna do
this today and a lot of the first of all
there's like you know scientific
evidence for certain health benefits or
whatever which are great that's not
really the reason I'm doing it I'm doing
it because it makes you feel really good
because you get like this burst of I
guess it's serotonin that lasts a few
hours
um but
I kind of go into this ritual where it's
like
that minute before you get in there is
this sort of
I'm gonna get into this thing and it's
gonna be very unpleasant especially the
moment of making the decision to get in
and lower yourself into this thing every
day and I'm and right now I've got it
it's a 51 degrees
it goes down to 39 and you're supposed
to like decrease like a degree a week I
started at 55. I'm gonna tell you right
now is that what I got into that you got
it at 55 which again 55 I mean I think
that's cool I'm gonna tell you right now
get in 55 degree water I don't think
that's cold it five to ten minutes and
you'll see I mean your body thinks that
you're dying if you you're doing
something that's going to kill you and
that's why it responds the way that it
does yeah but there's this like even
this morning when I was in there
hating it in the first like 30 seconds
and I kind of opened my hands up because
again opening your hands under the
surface of the water makes you that much
colder because your hands are I don't
know I can't remember the technical term
for some sort of surface that like your
heat escapes your hands you know
that's why covering wearing gloves like
actually does keep you warm
but like just sort of having this
breathing through the adversity
which that's a lot of people who do it
on a regular basis are like that's kind
of why they do it because you develop
this sort of physiological response to
adversity and you breathe through it and
you can learn to expect it and accept it
and kind of move through it
and in sort of their like long term
creates like a it makes you you know
more
willing to deal with adversity and so
I'm doing it because it makes me feel
good ironically that well I don't know
if it's ironic but like that's the thing
that
kind of motivates me to be interested in
it so I do like that philosophically
yeah and I think it might really does
you might get up tomorrow and find me in
it it really does you can come over and
use anytime you want it really does have
a sort of a youth there's a euphoria
that happens right after because I get I
get out of it I put a robe on
and then like go make my smoothie which
is you know full of olive oil and other
things and I'm like freezing in that
moment but I just like I'm
oh man I just I feel good can you take
like
footage of you doing this so that we
could we could um I could see this
happening I could probably be arranged I
mean I don't want a close-up or anything
but just like I'm naked inside of it are
you
um most of the time
we have guests right now so I'm not
naked in there just in case they come
down for breakfast or whatever
or a little bathing suit this morning
okay we'll do that but for the video or
like let's have some tasteful cropping
tasteful crap okay
I I don't think I had a big Splurge well
I've I think I bought my my DJ deck I
think that was this year it had to have
been yeah I'm sure for sure was okay
well here we are I you know it's my
wreck uh everything we've said today is
basically a wreck in one form or another
so um you know I'm gonna put it back to
the uh to the community birdhouse
littlefreelibrary.org
call that a birdhouse but you know what
I mean don't put birds in there put
books in there book house
#your biscuits
um we'll be back at you next week and
remember
let us know what you think by sending us
your voice
we got a couple which is two more
episodes before we wrap up the season is
that right yep yeah so we're going to
talk a little bit about our uh our
Thanksgiving break and then we're going
to cover our highlights for the year I
love it I love that one
what is up Rhett and Link this is Jacob
from Dallas Texas I also broke a
collarbone while mountain biking I broke
both of my collarbones at the same time
yeah healing process sucked it took
three months for me to fully heal and it
hurts when it gets cold thanks guys link
I hope you're all healed up properly
Rhett keep on growing out that hair boy
all right
[Music]
style the whistlers allow me to give you
the Kill Bill theme song
foreign
[Music]
thanks I hope I am the first to say
congratulations on your streamy show of
the Year award
I'm kind of in there to say I only found
y'all in 2019 but since then y'all have
become by far my favorite YouTubers ever
ever
love you guys congratulations to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right to watch the previous
episode of your biscuits click on the
playlist to the left and don't forget to
click on the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms thanks for being your
mythical best
[Music]